[Music]
US is filled to the brim with hidden
meanings metaphors and minor moments
that turn out to have huge consequences
behind them whilst the big twist in the
film is currently breaking the internet
there's actually a hidden twist that
many of missed and whilst this isn't
confirmed there's a lot of evidence to
support it that twist revolves around
why Jason is so weird and throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the theory behind why certain things in
the film happened to him this is full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
the movie yet then I highly recommend
that you turn off now without the way
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I explain it so you don't
have to ok so firstly just a quick recap
on the plot of us we follow Adelaide
Wilson who with the rest of her family
go to their Beach home on vacation
Adelaide has a lot of childhood trauma
from when she was attacked by a
doppelganger in the carnival that exists
on the beachfront she fears that whyever
attacked her is coming back and this has
proven right when the family are
ambushed by a group of people that are
exact duplicates of them it turns out
everyone in the United States has a copy
and these have risen to the surface from
their underground homes and are now
murdering people on mass the Wilsons
managed to kill most of their doubles
but Adelaide's double grabs the serna
Jason and descends into one of the
underground tunnels Adelaide follows her
and manages to kill her double and
escapes with her son seemingly saving
the day however in the end it's revealed
that when Adelaide was attacked by
doppelganger as a child she was actually
swapped and she is the copy with this
entire rising of the tethered of being a
quest for revenge against her so this
holds a lot of complications and there's
actually another twist which theorizes
that Jason Adelaide son who's also
swapped with the tethered version of
himself now before you start rolling
your eyes the first time I heard this as
well I thought it didn't make a lot of
sense but the more I looked into it the
more that I've seen that the evidence
definitely points towards it being true
from the ted-ed we learn that everyone
in the US has a duplicate of them that
possesses an inverse personality of
their original self
for example Gabe is goofy and pretty
late
back where as Abraham his mirror is
aggressive and imposing zora is pretty
much glued to her phone and his very
sarcastic whereas hombre is constantly
smiling even during death Jason is very
reserved wears masks plays in closets
and is regarded by many as strange and
weird during the day before the attack
his family remark that he seems to be
speaking a lot of new words and that he
has a new vocabulary in addition to this
on the beach the other kids make fun of
him because instead of building a
sandcastle he's building a sand tunnel
overall he seems to keep himself to
himself and stays out of people's way
avoiding that touch in hiding behind his
mask juxtaposing this Pluto red Sun is
social and tries to often hold his
mother's hand at no point in the film
does he physically attack someone he's
definitely the most gentle of the group
Pluto is even docile with Jason he
showcases his burnt face and the
situation only escalates because Jason
kicks him and flees locking him in the
closet in the end Pluto dies because
Jason realizes that he can control him
and sense him walking back into the fire
well some may think that he deliberately
attacked the car and caused it to leak
petrol he had numerous opportunities to
set it alight and still did not so what
does this all mean well the more you
think about it the more you realized
that Pluto actually shares the traits of
a surface dweller
whereas Jason doesn't and therefore it's
very likely that he was swapped out so
when exactly did this happen
well the air prior to the vacation seems
the most likely time we know that prior
to the current ripple Jason started a
fire that almost burned the house down
his family even comment on this and if
true then it would provide the perfect
opportunity to make the change what if
Jason started a fire was burned horribly
and in the confusion was found by Pluto
and taken underground where he was
replaced this explains why he has a new
vocabulary can no longer do a magic
trick that he was more than capable of
doing the year before why he likes to
build tunnels and also why he knows how
to control the tethered in addition to
this when the family are listening to I
got five on it
a delay tries to get Jason to snap to
the beat however he is clicking his
fingers backwards and is therefore
unable to do this just opposing this
before Plato's death he is snapping his
fingers perfectly as a normal person
would perhaps this is a signal to
Adelaide that he is her real son gave
even uses the fact that Jason hasn't
been the same since last summer to
convince Adelaide to go to the beach
which again adds more evidence that
something is wrong
during his time underground a red could
have taught him how to speak and this
could be how the swap was unnoticed when
the fire happened red too clearly has
some affection for the boy as when the
tethered invade the home she merely
tells Pluto to go and play with Jason
instead of attacking him this showcase
is perhaps that she is aware of the
truth what if at the end of the movie
the intense stare that Adelaide and
Jason share is actually Jason wondering
if Adelaide knows the truth and a smile
she gives him confirms that she does but
that's a secret that they will share
between themselves to me it's definitely
possible and upon seeing the film for a
second time
this theory definitely stacks up
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it and if you agree or disagree with
me make sure you leave them in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my full breakdown of the
movie which would be linked at the end
this is the channel for people who were
mad into movies
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe thanks again for taking
the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]